[Music]
anna is up in cleveland ohio anna how
can we help
hi there thank you for taking my calls
you bet um
so i just finished um i just graduated
from college in december
and i'm just i feel like i'm in a unique
situation i guess everybody does um i
wasn't able to do an internship because
of covid
and then on top of that um i i've been
looking for
a new job just to help pay the bills um
and
i
left an abusive relationship um earlier
in may
and um
with the relation with how it ended i
had called the police
and um
because of the nature of my my ex
he fabricated a police report um against
me that i came and like beat him up and
um and there's there i have all the
evidence in the world that i wasn't
there i could have a literal video of me
at like go walking into a hotel um
but so i'm
i'm trying to um apply for new jobs and
like with this degree and everything but
i'm
really worried um about how i'm going to
be perceived with this charge on my
record because um it's not who i am at
all and everybody who knows me would
know that um but i can't
prove that to a new employer and so i'm
just really not sure like
how to go about this because it feels
pretty deceiting yeah that's that's
heavy and i hate that that happened to
you i'm glad that you had the courage
and the strength and support to leave
that
abusive relationship and get rid of that
nonsense you're worth more than that i'm
glad you walked away
and unfortunately we live in a world
where anybody anytime can lob any
accusation any sort of anything against
any of us
they can file a suit for any number of
reasons
and
we have to rely on the process and the
people involved in that process
so
most of the time and i say 95 99 of the
time
a job is going to ask you have you ever
been convicted of
and your answer to that will be no
because anybody can file any sort of
thing against anybody anytime
and you will truthfully and honestly
answer no i haven't been convicted of
anything
and
if they happen to say are you under
investigation for anything
and you feel like having that
conversation then you can say i left an
abusive relationship and it's currently
um in investigation right now um but i
am
everything is just fine yeah anna could
you give us a quick update john i just
want some 401. you keep going but i is
is the matter solved now and he just he
kind of put out and the police showed up
to investigate because they have to is
this thing still open investigation or
is it done
um it's still going through like
pre-trial and trial yeah so it'll be an
event it'll be its own thing i got you
okay yeah and that stinks my guess is um
it
yeah depending it it it probably won't
make it out of it probably when you make
it to trial i just tell you right now if
you've got video shows that you were not
there uh unless you're a lawyer is a
complete buffoon and you can't show the
judge that
i want to encourage your heart john's
right that'll probably get thrown out
what kind of job are you looking for
i
well i i think really anything that pays
more than what i'm doing right now um i
i just graduated with an urban planning
and development degree but i'd love to
work with non-profit um
our
ideally i would also i have a couple
ideas in mind um
i would like to do stuff with community
development and like housing i'd like to
be an appraiser and then on the opposite
end be a flourish so
so how old are you do you mind me asking
your age
yeah i'm 30. okay very cool so you've
got this this mix of things um and i
think that right now um
before you search for any of those i
want you to kind of take a little bit of
time to get clear on this unless you're
just in dire straits financially are you
in some kind of a hurry to get a
different job than the one you have now
other than the fact that you just don't
like it it's a j-o-b
oh i love my job actually um and they're
super supportive and much employee of
the year and whoa they're awesome it's
just
yeah it's just not the work you want to
do long term
it's it's more so it just doesn't pay i
only make like 25 to 30k a year and it
was the job that i just got when i moved
to the area okay great but here's a good
stuff the reason i asked that question
you answered it you love it right now so
we don't have to be in a hurry so when i
hear
planning and urban development that's
what you went to get your degree in you
had some interest there we could at
least say that right um i don't know how
much your heart's involved with that but
then we talk about florist and then what
was the other one
um i'd like to do um appraising okay so
here's what i want you to do real estate
i want you to here's the deal i'm going
to give you a copy a free copy of of my
book the proximity principle okay
and and i want you to read it and do it
now here's the deal it's for people who
know what they want to do they're just
not quite sure the best way to get there
and you've got these multiple ideas and
it's going to work for you here's what i
want you to do okay it's going to really
hold you accountable but i want you to
go hang out with a florist or too and i
mean hang out
i mean like not just coffee or lunch say
could i shadow you for half a day i'll
actually help for free i just want to
get a sense i want to get in here and
get my hands dirty and i want to feel
what it's like i want my heart to be
able to register what it actually is
like to be a florist so you're going to
get a lot of head knowledge but you're
going to get a lot of heart knowledge as
well and i want you to do the same thing
with an appraiser you got to know
somebody who knows somebody who knows
somebody who appraises nobody wants to
shadow them trust me right so they'll
they'll do it and i want you to sample
this work do you understand what i'm
saying before we start looking for
anything else and i think that will help
you in this season with this this whole
court mess going on before we go looking
for something let's be pretty darn clear
about what we're looking for does that
make sense
yeah and anna i want to tell you
something and listen to me real
carefully okay
when you roll out of an abusive
relationship
everything about everybody
is that they're scary and they're going
to hurt you
because somebody said he loved you and
then he hurt you is that right
the only way this is this is what makes
abuse so evil
the only way to heal is through
relationship with other people which
means you gotta risk again you gotta
trust again so get a group of people
around you whether it's one two or three
or four people get an attorney that you
trust trust the judge to do the right
thing
and lean back into relationship
you're worth it i'm so proud of you for
being brave now you gotta go take the
next steps